I am back for another unaccept
unexpected stream
I screamed earlier today briefly and
this is going to be another brief stream
the Sun is pretty low in the sky hence
the sunglasses I don't know how to like
close the blinds in the window like
right in front of me so I'll be wearing
sunglasses for the next like half hour
anyway I want to play just a few games
if people want to challenge me feel free
I already have one challenge from big
yaro well play him guy play them before
I've won twice before camel clutch share
in the chat hello camel clutch err good
luck to my opponent let's play g6
haven't had like too many g6 openings
recently and someone in the previous
stream suggested that I play up here
it's and I fail to do that so this is
this is my Redemption we could play a
hippo g6 usually a good move when the
bishop goes to c4 I'll probably play a
six and just do this setup so before the
first round of the sync felt Cup Carlson
posted on Twitter a photo from the st.
Louis Zoo of him observing hippos and it
was the caption was something like
getting inspiration for round one and
then everyone was speculating that he
was gonna play the hippo in the first
round but that didn't happen
but this is me being inspired by
Magnus's tweets I think the the idea
here is to play King f8 - GA - h7 kind
of have to castle by hand because my
rook is tied down defending this pawn
and then it becomes a question how white
will eventually continue so many people
complimenting my shades thanks guys I
don't know if I can read that name the
shades make it harder to like see the
screen but they they protect my eyes
from the Sun so I feel like I feel like
James can t right now always wearing
sunglasses but at least now it's it's
it's functional
okay so c5 is a common idea which I
think makes sense to play right away I
don't see any reason to wait I'm common
idea especially with the double fee and
Kadota at some point execute the pawn
break and then at some later point to
execute the opponent but now I'm
planning something like Queen c7 and c4
maybe if I get lucky I can trap the
bishop or even some idea like c4 right
away then if he takes I can trade the C
pawn for the center pawn before
unexpected
what is b4 well now c4 looks attractive
c4 Bishop takes c4 Bishop to g4 let's do
it
and then I'll have some half-open c-file
to work with they'll probably look to
still play Queen c7 and then maybe rook
c8 and maybe you be more types of things
like Knight f5 or Knight d5 I just want
to keep applying the pressure and also
keep a time advantage too so he plays
like g3 okay let's move back over to
finding the pond so my rook has some
mobility and then later maybe I'll play
rook even rook c8 rook c7 and Queen
eight a very thematic idea
I like the setup hippo is so solid I
control all the squares on the fifth
rink but I'm not controlling or at least
defending the pond so do I want to play
Queen c7 I think it's okay
feels weird to put my queen on the same
diagonal as a bishop but someday I'll
play ninety five and destroy the bishop
unless he destroys me first
I was unexpected
that's a move like he's gonna get
compensation here hello - lemon chief I
could I mean I pretty much have to take
and just kind of weather the storm
doesn't seem Pleasant play 95 now d6 was
falling like this is unpleasant cuz
there's a lot of things attacked I could
play 95 play Knight c8 f 5 knife f5 also
neither fate looks like a good move
there's some funny line neither faith
Bishop take d6 and I take e 6 Bishop
takes e7 Knight takes you seven and I'll
have two bishops in there look for a
queen and a queen and three pots it
looks interesting I would be happy to
play that in balance I think
I can see like where the Sun is about to
set so it seemed like in m inutes it's
gonna fall below the tree line okay so
this is happening really interesting
imbalance so what's the point value rook
into bishops is 11 Queen and three pawns
is 12 but I feel like my minor pieces
should be superior as long as I can get
them to good squares
the problem is C 4 is coming and that
could be very unpleasant so maybe I'll
play rook e8 first rook e8 King h7 I
could take on f3 2 I could play Bishop
f6 first
and I'll start with rook e8
have to keep in mind like I could
sacrifice what kind of sacrifice maybe I
shouldn't sacrifice anything wingnut
this is your first time watching me on
Twitch I usually don't have shades this
is actually my first time ever streaming
with sunglasses and it's simply it's not
a fashion statement it's just trying to
be functional because literally my setup
is kind of facing the window I'm too
lazy to figure out how to close the
blinds so ok now I can play Knight e5
and attack the Queen some scary stuff
about to happen but probably just have
to allow it usually it's easier to play
these positions when you have the Queen
because it's harder to coordinate for me
I have to coordinate all my pieces but
if I can do so correctly I feel like it
should be okay Wesley so style I tweeted
something today I tweeted it was just a
gift from the from the broadcast with
Wesley like putting up his sunglasses
the caption was Wesley bond
okay now King age 7 was my original
intention because I have to connect my
rooks especially have to defend their
work on Yeats
and then yeah I think this could get
could start getting messy especially if
he plays a move that I don't really want
him to play well maybe it's not too bad
though but maybe it is bad this is
really scary there's some crazy line I
think I have to play Knight c8 here only
move
I don't see any other options
I could play rook to Yates that's
another option because if I play tonight
see it then he plays um he ticks on yay
then plays Queen sees or Queen d7 or
even Queen d7 right away
I've worked th first I'm attacking the
Queen Queen e6 is forced still have to
untangle Bishop c8 Queen e2 that's not
good Oh Queen e2 9 f4 then he takes yeah
this isn't good
well there's a funny idea I can play
nine of six in some position I think
I'll go for Knight f6 but I'm starting
with rook t8
so I'm counter attacking the Queen and
the plan is to play Knight f6 here and
the trick is that if he takes a knight I
take his knight which leaves the rook
last offended that I have rookie eights
and my knight supports e8 which is
important so that took a lot of time to
figure out I could still be worse
somehow but at least I'm surviving
I shouldn't like having moobot command
every every time someone says nice
shades I should just have like
Commandments as thanks I appreciate all
the compliments
okay b6 I forgot was hanging but at
least he's not winning a minor piece I
think I should still take on f3 I should
take on f3 cuz my knight and Bishop were
hanging also this is 10 plus 0 this is
casual so hopefully I won't lose any
rating points and I think the strategy
for this position is just to attack or
somehow try and formulate some attack
he's considering this move which could
be very unpleasant yeah this is bad
I completely forgot who you play that
because now this is a threat
oh no mm I'm just gonna lose us unless I
can somehow tricking this is really bad
I have 47 d7 I don't think works I could
try it okay let's try it because I don't
see anything else
so this is not going to end well unless
somehow it ends well but yeah not good
because now I have a bishop and a rook
for Queen and oh did he just oh no he
didn't plunder thought he blundered
rookie eights but here's a night of fun
so Bishop and rook
maybe I'm getting counterplay oh that
moves that move kills my counter play
what to do
bishop f8
I'm trying I mean I have the bishop pair
you should never resign when you have
the bishop pair I still go for a counter
play he's playing a good game like he uh
he went for the sacrifice or the
material imbalance and it's working out
for him so what to do maybe take yeah
that's a good move but I'll play this
still going for a counter play did he
just hang b5 that's a free pawn
I need more gifts like that if you can
keep giving me free stuff I would be
very grateful this is bad because that's
a gigantic threat but maybe it's not
over or maybe it is wait rocky one no
it's not over
but it's not looking that great
just have to figure out how I keep the
tension you'll start with rookie Rookie
one then Bishop a6 and queen a seven
Bishop g7 I'm actually threatening to
almost trout the night okay at least my
king is safe
time isn't great am i chopping the night
h4 yes tonight each one is playable but
that's not what he wants
okay this is gonna be entertaining if he
has to play that each one then I have
counter play
problem is that there's not too much
counter play maybe I play rock f1 here
preventing preventing f5
was again unexpected he wants to free
the night clearly
let's do this
yeah I'm hiding my tears that's exactly
why I'm wearing the sunglasses
I'm just sobbing inside right now but
anyway at least my pieces are kind of
coordinating like Bishop defends a king
my other rook and Bishop can start
attacking interesting move let's do this
ideas of this Miss also ideas of this
I'm making him think very soon those
sunglasses will come off I have to get
serious here I think I have to take 94
okay let's do this
pinning the night's time is very
important okay
oh let's do that what is going on here
he's not meeting me I mean he has
perpetual but my ponds about to promote
he's trying to flag me I'm happy with a
draw he wants a draw
do I want to draw
I'm declining the draw I'm going crazy
oh no that's mate
Queenie sevens mate okay draw ah that's
unlucky because he was expecting me to
play King age 7 and in an alternate
universe I could just take the free
night the Queen age sevens mates so
could I go back to I mean the final
position should be winning for whites on
how I was a weird draw well at least I
survived that yes it should be it should
have been easy win yeah King h8
unfortunately doesn't work cuz Queen D
eights and he's just mating me but maybe
yeah maybe already it's not so easy for
a white because he really can't stop the
pawn from promoting I don't want stock
fish enabled too soon uh there was a
really funny thing I was really hoping
for like let's imagine let's imagine I
play King h5 and he takes on g7 I was
hoping that some line like this could
work out where I promote tonight King
III and then rookie to checkmates
this would have been epic but I think
there's a few things wrong with us first
of all he can just play this and I have
no more mate 92 doesn't lead to anything
oh wait a minute
I play king h5 in the game so he had the
chance to take on g7 what's going on
here
oh yeah promoting tonight doesn't work
but maybe I could play I can play this
move this is winning for a black I think
because the King has to go here here and
then I Queen with check that's just a
win so I kind of wish he he actually
acknowledged that I play King h5 because
there there would be a chance he would
go for Queen take g7 so the ultimate
question is is the final position that
draw or can white play for a win after
g2
I think it's just a draw at this point I
think he I mean he had an opportunity
just to take this should be somehow
winning for whites
anyway let's uh okay let's get an answer
from sock fish enable and then Knight g4
an IG for just draw and then after King
h5 still a draw queen d8 is interesting
covering d5 and threatening Queen here
mate and then the only move to survive
is Bishop h6 Wow Wow Knight f6 what does
this line Knight g4 if I take on h3 oh
there's not enough to wait let's
investigate this is insane but somehow
my king is finding shelter and where are
both of our kings are very close to
getting mated I would think in many of
these lines anyway that was a cool game
it's a cool sunset I know if I can show
people the sunset without like breaking
my computer I think it's too risky
I'll take a photo let's take a photo
look at this can people see this
that's the view for my window the Sun is
just like a orange dot in the sky also
Ignat Phu thanks for the the follow okay
do I end it there or do I play one more
game I'm probably ending it there
because I I'm gonna get Thai food but
I'll be back in the future I'll be back
tomorrow for the chess column arena
Kings tournament starting at 12 p.m.
Central time and I might even do a
stream on me chess right before that but
I'll see a canoe sorry if you just got
here
thanks for the 50 bits donks showing
some love yeah I love bits but I love
Thai food a lot more so people want more
lemon chief okay so who can I read all
probably I'm gonna end the stream and
then I might grade someone so stick
around for just a few more a few more
seconds but anyways I will be back
tomorrow